so what's the new model you know one of
the new models that we've seen actually
at the event here in Abu Dhabi is
actually the aging monograph that is
being created by the Global Agenda
Council on Aging and what that is is
that is looking at aging in a whole new
light to not only looking at what the
burdens are but also looking at what the
opportunities are whether it's health
care whether it's marketing but you know
it really doesn't matter it it's really
helping to rethink the way we look at
aging and that there's a new model unto
itself because the way we typically look
at aging is not one in a positive light
in many instances and this monograph
will actually help hopefully create just
that